c'est olivier dassault pour le groupe
l'est républicain merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
chiffre d'affaires spectaculaire courbe
mirifiques annonce extraordinaire et
démonstrations en tous genres le
gouvernement est devenu expert dans
l'art d'annoncer les bonnes nouvelles
la dernière en date la suppression de
l'effort fiscal national pour plusieurs
millions de contribuables venait d'en
parler d'en reparler mais se trompe
l'oeil ne cache-t-il pas en réalité une
multitude de mesures qui contrôlent cher
très cher aux français nous voulons la
vérité
pourquoi encore et toujours de nouvelles
augmentations notamment des impôts
locaux j'y reviens en raison du report
sur les collectivités l'école locale de
l'effort fiscal national et des taxes
foncières sur les terrains non bâtis
qu'est devenue cette pause fiscale
promise lorsque vous ajoutez 3,4
milliards d'euros et chers collègues sur
le revenu déjà hyper concentré d'un
français sur deux comment justifiez-vous
qu'un couple avec deux enfants gagnant
4000 euros par mois paie plus d'impôts
qu'en 2012
pourquoi toujours et encore pénaliser
les classes moyennes qui sert depuis
trois ans de portefeuille à votre
majorité
ils ont déjà payé près de 20 milliards
d'impôts supplémentaires depuis 2012 ce
ne sont plus simplement des
haut-le-coeur que vous provoquez mais de
l'allergie oui de l'allergie fiscal
grâce à vous docteur nous sommes des
chefs relais du monde mais en à pau en
tout n'a eu
savez-vous qu'à partir de 2016 il y aura
autant de taxes que deux jours dans
l'année
alors monsieur le premier ministre sur
prenez nous vous qui avez su faire
preuve d'imagination politique en termes
d'imposition
n'hésitez pas à mettre votre talent au
service de tous les français en faisant
preuve d'équité et d'efficacité en
matière d'économie baisser les impôts
sans discrimination baisser les dépenses
sans modération c'est possible d'autres
l'ont fait avant vous ici en france mais
aussi ailleurs chez nos voisins
européens
alors pourquoi pas vous merci monsieur
dassault la parole est à monsieur
christian eckert secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
d'assaut vous fait le défenseur des
classes moyennes et nous adresser une
rafale de compliments je vous en
remercie mais plus sérieusement
plus sérieusement je voudrais dire la
vérité parce que dire la vérité aux
français
c'est faire le constat que les baisses
d'impôts que vous propose le
gouvernement est que vous ne contestez
pas d'ailleurs je vous en remercie les
baisses d'impôts que propose le
gouvernement dans ce projet de loi de
finances concerne les classes les plus
modestes les classes moyennes mais
parallèlement monsieur le député aucune
augmentation d'impôts n'a été prévu pour
les autres et vous parlez de la
concentration de l'impôt sur le revenu
monsieur le député je vais vous donner
deux chiffres aujourd'hui aujourd'hui 10
% des français payent 67 4 % des impôts
sur le revenu
retenez ce chiffre savez-vous quel était
ce chiffre en 2011
en 2011 les 10 francs
les 10 % des français les plus aisés en
payer 72 % c'est-à-dire plus
qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'impôt sur le revenu n'est
pas plus concentré qu'en 2011 monsieur
le député est aujourd'hui si une plus
d'une moitié de français ne payent pas
l'impôt sur le revenu
tous payent la tva la csg qui sont de
loin les deux impôts qui profite le plus
alors soyez assuré monsieur le député ce
projet de loi finances épargne cette
fois l'ensemble des français et
concentrent les baisses d'impôts sur les
foyers modestes et vous et les français
moyens dont vous avez si bien parlé
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
amène à millas
elle le calme